our employees were worried because we
were dating they're like what happens if
you guys break up I was like it's a good
point I understand their concerns I came
in with flowers and I was like these are
for you so I've been thinking I think it
would make sense if we got married I did
never rang I didn't do the one knee down
thing she like looked at me and I was
like well what do you think and she was
like yeah I guess so and I was like okay
well then I guess we need to go get you
a ring well there's a jewelry store
around the corner and so we got in the
car went to the grocery store he looked
at a bunch and she was like I like that
one I was like I like that one too we
bought it in 10 minutes went back to the
apartment and I was like I guess we have
to do the church thing so I called it
the church are you free Wednesday and he
was like yeah and we worked that
Wednesday and then after work we went to
the church we got married with Noah no
family didn't tell anybody we got
married we showed up to work the next
day told the staff you're good all your
concerns have been accounted for we are
married that was it been rocking and
rolling since